hi I'm Nick Gillespie and I'm here with
my reason colleague Matt Welch where the
co-authors of the Declaration of
Independence how libertarian politics
can fix what's wrong with America our
new question at ask a libertarian is
from Carmen caldron via reason.com
Carmen asks what do you think is the
best course of action for libertarian
minded people working through the two
major parties are pushing to advance a
third party such as the Libertarian
Party Matt well if you're asking us for
political advice you're probably in a
world of hurt I don't think that there's
a one true way of figuring out how to
interface with politics and affect
things in a way that make you happier
but one source one method that we talk
about a lot in the book is finding a way
to be independent from those two
political parties in a way that actually
the Tea Party has done if you contrast
what the Tea Party has done compared to
the anti-war movement on the left the
anti-war movement Howard Dean movement
God subsumed within the Democratic
Democratic Party Mon machinery and is
dead it's effectively been neutralized
the Tea Party has kept an arm's length
from the Republican Party has challenged
them has proven to be crazy enough to
back people who have no chance of
winning and because of that they've
retained their potency so one way
paradoxically to inflict your own
politics onto a system that isn't
working is by refusing to participate in
the same politics as usual the two major
parties yeah I'm totally down with that
I also think I would love to see
libertarian there's a libertarian wing
or strain or flavor or grouping in the
Republican Party I'd love to see that
build out in the Democratic Party it's
got a heritage they're going back to
people like Grover Cleveland but let's
see more libertarians everywhere
including at the goddamn water cooler
telling you about why you should get the
government out of Iraq and out of Rhode
Island all at the same time